あイタイイタイイタイイタイよかったお前がいないと始まらないですよ師匠とせたい
このちゃんとしてどうかもしれない様子コニーちゃん肇社長です1ダース今今年中に
明らかにしておきたいことが一つは何か
そう pope じゃねカルピスの原液がありますそうみんな知ってるか知らないけど
カルピスって薄めて飲んだんですねこの壁店まで元気だぞ
苦いんですよ5倍に薄めて15杯分5番に集めなきゃいけないんですそう
上の子ピンにプランのペットボトルのカルピスは実の子の完結の原液を薄めたやつなん
ですよつまりこれが本当のカルピスほんとで薄めて飲むとねこれ一杯で何回もノベルん
ですよあまり飲んだことないからよくわかんないんですけども
あーケーキで飲んだことはあんまりないんですよねたぶんすっごいこいと
もんでしょん
re
gackt わぁ芸妓のまますぐに外んだけどもうここに書いてあると言って5番に
染めて飲んでみましょう
ぐらいかなお水アーマー色て芸カルピスとはまさにカルビ時になります
美味しいそこで私は考えたなぜからピザ水で薄めるの過去がにを薄める方法はたくさん
あるんじゃないかって僕は考えなければというで今は主要な飲み物を準備しました水は
普通三ツ矢サイダーコーラオランジーナ取りせって多いよツアーを選ばれたのは綾た
ああああ
アーサーフィルパーズ後はブラックのコーヒーだけこのメンツの中でどうやってが一番
カルピスと相性がいいかってことちょっとね尻だけだったわけなんですよ
間違いなく水ではない俺の脳みそがそう言ってるピヴォマーニャもっと相応しい女が
いるんですね今宵はこの0 d の中からお前が一番好きな女を持ち帰っていそうだの
みんな
俺何言ってんだちょっとまずそうなやつから十分に行きたいと思いますまずは前田方姫
で待って102年間に美味しいコーヒーに言うと振らなきゃパクらないでくださいって
書いてるよねこれはね逆にね砂糖と混じって美味しいなんかここはとかさあ佐藤恵美の
はコーヒー牛乳みたいになる可能性は大きい
悪くないですよではまずコーヒーかける家族していただけます
ごめんねはないで次行ってっ
次はビエでいきたいとおもいます店には飲んじゃダメだぞアホれもさあこれをやったら
おいしい可能性あるぞ
命令のパルピストあるみたいなさ基本的にはこんな感じです
なんか人とニッペシャンディーガフジントニック3 d 風邪みたいにオシャレな匂い
がしますではいただけます
えっ
飲みやすいぞ甘い甘いよ俺したおかしいのかビールまで好きじゃないってはっきりなく
おいしくなってなにこれうまいですねっ
まっであってうまいぞびっくりする旨さなんだけどいやーそんな長はないといけじゃ
ないよ落ち着けオレが持ってるだけかもしれんただ僕の意見からするとめちゃくちゃ
美味し
すごい飲みやすいすぎっ次はこちらああああっ
poo
おーいお茶お茶はで違うと思うんですよねこれねーはこんな色でございますでは
いただきます
ん
あっは
な地図しもあらずで何かナニカルピスって結構万能オーナーの方へお茶とかるっていう
アイマス配分がいいのかなぁわかんないんですけどもなんだろ lipton リプトン
これ二人で行くと多いをちょっとカルピスのデビッド南下しますピーチティーみたいな
グループ巨乳になるんですよ見やすいのは飲めずいな
読みやすいなぁやば塗ってないぞ次こっち周りとなると綾鷹もいけるんじゃない
でしょうか
じゃあ行ったが合えば行きまーすの結局さんでも多いをちょっとやってること同じだ
からさああんまり違いはないと思うんだよいただけます
選ばれた川彩タケかわいいよアー
はいっ
次行きましょうここからはちょっと音がわりと甘い+甘いなんでハズレではないと思う
んですけども他にセット行ってみようと思います数万ってお腹泊してきたから少なめで
空間ぺーコメントしづらいにょオランジーナねこれねまぁ道られそうだと思いますよ
来いかっっ
もうちょっと上へいけると思ってた三ツ矢サイダーレッスンた安定的な味になると思う
いただきます
カルピスソーダよくがコーナーで作用でパシッとおいしくいってほしいものですよ
うーんちょっと薄汚い甲板
ん
me ん
ドリンクバーの味が良く混ぜる感じだなよく考えたらやったことあるいは kohler
コーラーがも飲んだ方が美味しいし和美炸裂ままだった方が美味しいでした
わって言うとか美味しい gsk ば別にまあどっちの面ですけども折っちゃうと b
でがビックリしましたをちゃんとビールとカルピスだねこの子たちはなかなか
美味しかったです
お腹痛い
明日はたぶん今年のまとめとかね2015年のダイジェストとかまとめチックな動画に
なると思いますじゃあな